Ukraine became the country with the
largest Minefield in the world in 2022
after Russia infested its lands with
mines some of which are the cruel
butterfly mine a mine that can be aird
dropped over massive areas thanks to its
small helicopter seed-like Wings one
Ukrainian farmer desperate to start
cultivating their land again has
retrofitted a tractor with armor
shielding a rotating drum to detonate
the mines and even made it remote
controlled so they can clear the mines
from a safe distance hiding inside the
metallic scoop of an excavator raised
into the air to give them a clear
vantage point of their work who knows
maybe they can start using the equipment
they stole from retreating Russian
soldiers and they will need it because